uh there's i this isn't no of course
this isn't this water but so there are
you know there are set twos you have
some touchy moments and words and
obviously you can kill them but
uh can we talk about the sex scene it's
one of the best sex scenes i've seen in
forever oh that's sexy who put that
together you know seriously
[Laughter]
you
no it's not and it's not i'm well it's
not like they're kind of like prancing
around naked it's just it's a really
clever
so who who put did you guys put that
together did ricky scott put it together
no we had nothing to do with that
excuse me i'm just trying to cover my
universe over here
and of course it's not just you in it uh
other screen legends jeremy are you sexy
jeremy
jeremy was particular
he was great he was behind the camera
why are you having sex
when we heard about we were promised it
was going to be like this you know
really raunchy sexy and i was watching
it where is the sex but my god once you
pull the rip cord it's it's non-stop
there's a bit
i mean even you must have been kind of
you know at the table reed you must have
been going blah blah blah i haven't
spoken for pages
well i got my mouth full half a time
which i was consistent because i think
that's important to see on tv as well
because
that is uncommon that you see that kind
of power dynamic in rauchi scenes and
that's part of the way that we did want
to modernize the show so the duke does
have his mouth full and he's proud of it
um but yes there was there was a fair
bit um to be done on the show because
you're really going for it but you're
going for it in kind of beautiful
locations
i mean like and occasionally very
uncomfortable locations well yeah those
library steps didn't look easy um
but didn't you have didn't you have room
monitors in the stately homes well this
is a problem because the set as usual is
more valuable than any of the actors so
if you're in like you know a 200 year
old bed or a 400 year old four poster um
it has to have a reminder like you know
when people kind of bring very expensive
jewelry around they have to have a
bodyguard there's a bodyguard for the
room and so all times you know you've
got this minimal set everyone gets very
quiet very respectful and you kind of
you de-robe and you hit the bed and then
there's also just like fran in the
corner who's just standing there just
kind of deciding whether or not to look
she's like i have to look i'm not
allowed to look i have to look
could you please go easy on the bed it's
very very hard it's not quite so
enthusiastic oh do go on
that's the inner monologue that i
imagine
is going on in the corner i'll stop them
in a minute
and presumably you had to have the
awkward
kind of family conversation before yeah
a little bit um i mean we've got a
family whatsapp group so there's a
couple of you know flash and red light
emojis and the odd peach emoji um
certain people have threatened to rate
my peach
but we missed a couple of family lenders
and so people who enjoy the fact that
like a couple of cousins missed the memo
um and so they're watching the show and
i got a very stern message in my my
instagram dms id enough just going
there really needs to be a cousin
warming i had to make so many tactical
cups of tea and i left the room and made
my tactical cup of tea and came back and
you were still going so you had to start
doing pots of tea you know you had to
kind of kind of keep building up the
course meal a tasting menu
now you've worked with uh mr tucci
haven't you kate yes hello
hi gabe yeah see gary goes gagging on
his boobs i know i know i'm very happy
to see you very very happy to see you
too so presumably you've experienced uh
stan lee's cooking no i haven't
experienced stanley's cooking um which
is a tragedy because clearly you're a
marvelous chef but sally do you remember
how much you complained when we worked
together he would come into work and he
would say after breakfast half an hour
late he'd say i'm i mean i'm starving i
mean there's there's nothing to eat
i mean
what do you do there's there's no food i
mean this is awful this is this is just
awful and then the next day he came into
work carrying this very sort of neat and
tidy little cooler bag actually it was
quite a large cooler bag to be fair and
it was full of these perfectly prepared
little tupperware's full of incredible
delights and everyone's like oh leaning
in oh stanley he's like no
[Laughter]
well yeah you know
you're you you know you have to eat well
don't you when you're working you have
to eat well i don't want to throw in
there at this point but i was in fact
pregnant when yes no i know you didn't
even feel the pregnancy no i know and i
didn't know that but you told me that
on the set she told me she said i i
can't remember what we were talking
about but you said i'm pregnant
and and she did that scream whisper you
know yeah and i said oh yes i did wonder
you yes you look really fat awful you
look really fat your boobs are huge but
you're still not having any of my snacks
yeah even though you're eating for two
yeah you're reading for two this
tupperware is sealed listen rosie i mean
you are quite unfiltered on your podcast
about your own
yes yes
well weirdly we don't actually talk
about us personally having sex because
we haven't had it twice
but it's been two really powerful times
exactly why do it again
it worked
we found out that we're actually quite
boring
because of what people send us in it's
pure smut yeah really the stuff people
send we are really boring one of our
first ones that we got sent that really
struck a chord with everyone was some
lady wrought in i see a lady
she said because he said he got any
questions and she wrote in and she said
i i need some advice because i'm and
this is the reason
i'm giving my husband his first foursome
this wednesday
wow
our initial thought was
uh wednesday sounds like a saturday yeah
you get it you can't ever force him on a
win
i suppose it's easier to park on a
wednesday
that is true
and if you're doing a foursome you
probably don't know what day it is
anyway
we've had people that we sadly missed
along the way you had the great prince
on your show uh i have a good i have a
great prince story prince one time
prince is coming on the show and his his
manager calls and says hey prince uh
would love a ping-pong to play ping-pong
on the show
i go okay uh we'll get a ping-pong table
no problem so he comes on the show we
have the never brings up ping-pong
doesn't talk about it never brings it up
doesn't even mention it i go whatever he
cra he crushes he's awesome he's great
that's the end of that and a month later
i'm at dinner and i get a text and i go
it says from hi this is prince's manager
prince wants to meet you right now at a
club
called spin in new york city uh it's a
nightclub it's a ping-pong nightclub
what so i go to my friend go i gotta go
prince wants to play me in ping-pong
he wants to meet me on 23rd and i go i
gotta go so i get in the cab i go to
this place i go down the steps uh
downstairs and i go hi i'm i'm here to
see um
in the girls
print
yeah
he's in this the private room back there
behind the curtain i go okay so i go in
i open this curtain and who's standing
there with prince in a double-breasted
uh
like crushed velvet suit and uh he's
holding a ping-pong paddle and he goes
you ready for this
and i go uh
yeah this is so surreal there's no one
else in the room just me and prince so i
go uh oh i guess i go he goes do you
want to warm up i go it doesn't matter i
mean i'm not even good at ping pong but
i'll play with you and he's like uh oh
here we go and so he's he's he serves
and he gets the point and he goes one's
it i go oh we're gonna talk smack here
we go let's go prince let's go let's
play now i'm like ready to play prince
i'm like let's go so i'm trying to play
back i'm not good at ping pong long
story long uh he's crushing so he's like
game point i go okay and he hits this
serve
and it's like
and it's one of those perfect ping-pong
the things are spinning flames are
coming off the ball and it's coming and
it hits that one corner of the ping-pong
table you know that's impossible to hit
back and he hits the thing and go and he
goes i go oh my gosh you won you won you
know let me go so i
look over to pick up the ball i come
back and uh he's gone
he's gone
and i don't know that well so i'm like
prince
is he hiding under the table so i'm like
print
prince
it was so weird i go and i walk out and
there's like a velvet rope and it was
kind of swinging back and forth a little
bit it sounds like batman was there or
something
and then questlove who's our band leader
here you know from the roots
heard about this ping-pong game and took
a cab over it and he actually saw
prince's limo uh outside and uh he went
up to it and he goes uh
wait did you guys already play what
happened and prince rolled his window
down he goes
ask your boy and then they just peeled
off and then
i never saw him again
i love that you're kind of in a
ping-pong basement like you're calling a
dog just going princess
i didn't know i didn't know if he was
hiding or what it was bizarre bizarre
how hard is this to be that mean to
harry mellon he is like the sweetest
individual in the world
because uh yes he played harry with his
name's harry melling and you i mean
that was exciting for you to do a scene
with harry melling it's a moment
yeah
harry manning was her rihanna
tell us why tell us why he meant so much
to you well i learned to speak english
reading the harry potter books so as
lame as it sounds those characters
really were my first friends um so still
a big fan of the harry potter franchise
love the movies oh my god look at him he
played dudley dursley i mean he's not an
obvious one but so many people don't
come up to him all the time
he's still part of the universe
and so what what language were you
speaking when you learned to speak
english through harry potter spanish
oh okay
and yeah
so when did you come to london when i
was six but i only learned english when
i was eight because i was convinced that
if i didn't speak the language my
parents would have to take me home and
that failed miserably so yeah i had to
learn now weirdly we have sort of met we
have kind of met yeah not on the show
this is my first time on i'm a little
nervous so forgive me if i ramble but we
i was doing um a broadway show called
hedwig and the angry inch
and you i had heard that you were going
to be in the audience and it was this
really nasty kind of rock and roll
uh punk rock musical and you had sat in
the very very front row if i'm not in
the middle
in the middle of i didn't book these
tickets
now and you were with two other guys and
during the show there's a part where
where hedwig who's pretty randy and
nasty
um uh you know there's a good picture of
her she uh she crawls in on down to the
stage and just picks someone in the
audience and makes out with them so um i
started down i i scanned the crowd i saw
you i went right for you and i you know
i grabbed my tongue down your throat
i i have the taste of cheap lipstick in
my mouth for the rest of the show
so nice to meet you on this second day
nice to talk to you finally i was
particularly pleased that the first
story you ever told on the show about 20
years ago is in the book it's the one
where uh you'd park on a double yellow
line for a few moments do you know the
story oh yes yes well that that had its
repercussions of course because well i i
mean i parked on a double yellow line in
shaftsbury avenue it was um the day of
the state opening of parliament
and i rushed up to give a take a tape an
audio tape because you know i do audio
tapes to my agent and i came downstairs
there was a policeman
pasting um a parking
ticket on my windscreen
and i was just furious because i'd only
been there for a minute and so you know
i tore it off the windscreen and i said
you've got a dick that small
because i thought the best thing is to
insult him as quickly as possible
of course and he took umbrage
didn't like it and he arrested me
for uh breach of the piece
and uh parking on a double yellow line
and um then he called for help from
other policemen and there were lots
about because it was the state opening
of parliament and you know they're
mingling around and so um i was taken in
a in a police car to beau street police
station
and
there i was arraigned
they said
empty your handbag and i had a few
things in my handbag and one of them was
a packet of peppermints but they're
wrapped in silver paper you see and that
the detective
in charge thought that it was drugs
and he said um
you know what if we got here then that's
interesting and i said it's just a
packet of peppermints officer
and he said no i think we better check
you out matron and he got the um the
matron to come and
uh put me in a room
privately
and i knew
i knew because i was sharp
that she was going to give me an
internal examination i just knew that
nothing had been said but i knew it so
when she locked the door she went out
for a bit i took all my clothes off
immediately
well you would you know you know you're
going to be examined
and she came back in and she said
you've been here before
i said i have not been here before she
said yes you have how did you know to
take your clothes off
and i said well i know you're going to
examine me aren't you they called you
matron so i knew something was afoot
so
she said anyway bend down or lie on the
couch or something and
she
examined me my front body and my back
and of course they thought i wouldn't
like it
[Laughter]
all right heard you talking somewhere in
there how your height difference makes
those stunts more complicated thank you
graeme
i didn't say it didn't destroy it
now that is a good story it's like a
story well you see there's there's a
particular stun there i don't know if
it's in this but there's a you know he
spider-man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there and that's the
bridge yeah that's the bridge we
eventually jump off that i'm
yeah um
so
he's supposed to gently you know rest mj
on the bridge and walk away from her
it because of our height difference i
obviously if we're on the same like
point we were attached i would land
before him because my feet obviously hit
the ground before he does
so
what would happen
it's called a bottom mark isn't it and
the bottom mark is to basically it's a
thing that they do in stunts that is
basically designed to stop you
shattering your kneecaps oh yeah so
zendaya would land and i'm the superhero
i'm supposed to look cool
and she would land and then i would sort
of land like this and my feet would
swing from underneath me and then she
would catch me
[Laughter]
you're actually very very lovely about
you were like oh my gosh thank you it's
so nice to be caught for a change
[Music]